Matt Bomer says he can't wait to see  Lady Gaga slay on the big screen  Matt attended a benefit for the one  pulse foundation in LA on Friday the  actor stayed tight-lipped about any  American Horror Story teasers for the  upcoming season I know nothing you know  you're a part of it though I will see  you know I'm always on when Ryan Murphy  cause I say yes but he had nothing but  high praises for his cast mate Lady Gaga  who landed her first lead role in a  feature film  how about Gaga being in the stars born  how about that that's fantastic I mean  she's gonna slay that she is gonna slay  that I'm so excited I'll be there  opening night front row right popcorn  ready Matt also hilariously told et  about his first experience at a gay bar  I snuck in underage the beer and akshat  but I used my brother's ID and guy was  the tightest 21 yet this isn't Houston  yeah yeah I don't remember the name of  though but it was a lot of fun I'm sure  you remember that about yeah good